comenzamos hablando del líder
republicano en el senado mitch mcconnell
a quien escuchábamos hace un momento con
de nueva trampa en su discurso pero al
mismo tiempo votó por la absolución por
considerar inconstitucional juzgar a un
ex presidente y además fue él mismo
quien retrasó el inicio del juicio
cuando trump aún era presidente como
explica su postura
bueno ese es uno de los debate que se va
generando él está tratando de mantener
control sobre el partido republicano que
está dividido claramente entre los que
tienen miedo por un lado de ser de tener
primarios contra la calidad de trump de
ser como castigado he protestado por
parte de lo que apoyan a trump el trump
mantiene control sobre el partido
republicano como ex presidente ha dejado
instalado muchas personas allá y
mexicano que quiere mantener su poder
dentro del senado como líder si en un
momento por ejemplo en dos años más se
cambia el equilibrio que tenemos
actualmente puede ser de nuevo
presidente senador no se sabe que tiene
que mantener ese equilibrio y demoró
mucho para hacer presente su oposición
de cierta manera como su apoyo
a la posición de los demócratas
esencialmente porque uno de los
comentarios que ha ido circulando tiene
que ver con que lo que dijo el mexicano
no hay final cierto la palabra que
escuchamos una parte del discurso era
más fuerte a continuación que todos los
argumentos que había presentado el
equipo demócrata adelante todo que fue
el proceso cierto no sé en ese sentido
me tomé kameni está en una posición el
partido republicano está dividido y
seguramente el partido demócrata tiene
un plan por lo que va a armando adversos
de las próximas semanas y fue creciendo
su capacidad de abordar los temas de la
agenda de paren pero también de ir
generando un recurso donde ha partido de
un demócrata es patriótico defendiendo
la constitución etcétera como se están
buscando transformar los recursos que
existen sobre la democracia y que
implica defender la democracia
y finalmente usted cree que después de
esta segunda absolución donald trump
afianza su poder en el futuro del
partido republicano como pinta la
próxima etapa para el magnate en la
política
y honestamente pienso que no si uno mira
la cantidad de personas que llegaron a
ese la instrucción que hubo algún
porcentaje pero pequeñísimo se habían
generado estadounidenses pueden ser que
son republicanos parece no implica que
están a favor de la violencia en general
la gran mayoría estaba shockeado por lo
que pasó ahora el medio de comunicación
juega un rol muy importante para
construir esa imagen y si uno mira por
ejemplo foxnews tenía casi nada de
cobertura sobre el tema
bersin nn que era solamente sobre el
impeachment rosters como se me parece
que también la ley de comunicación en
los próximos años tiene un rol muy
importante para ir fortaleciendo la idea
de una democracia y una visión de lo que
es eeuu y cuáles son sus desafíos
compartidos entre yo creo que donald
trump puede mantenerse
pero al final un discurso más de
esperanza yo creo que va a ganar